dr ephraim sudov welcome
thank you so um
please tell me in in short what would
you what would you say your job consists
of
i would say that it's one-third
detective
one-third historian and one-third
political lobbyist in other words the
detective
defined the people the historian to
collect the evidence
whether it's documents or or testimony
of witnesses and the political lobbyists
to try
and make sure that there's political
will to bring these people to trial
in the countries which in theory should
prosecute them
so what would you say so far in your
long career
has been your greatest victory do you
have do you have one
i think the one that stands out is
really the uh prosecution and conviction
and punishment
of a man named dinko shockache
who was one of the commanders of the
worst camp
in the balkans a camp called yasenovats
where at least a hundred thousand people
were murdered
serbs jews roma and anti-fascist
croatians
and we were able to find him and expose
him in argentina
and fight for his extradition to make
sure that he would be
you know extradited from argentina one
of the difficult
questions was where should he be put on
trial and
uh we under we realized that the country
that needed
that trial the most was croatia
where so many people still supported the
eustachia who are the croatian fascists
and had a certain nostalgia
for the eustachia but it was a gamble
because the president of croatia at that
time a man named franio tujman
is the only western head of state who
ever denied the holocaust
shockache said that nothing unusual
happened
in yasenovats that every country has a
penal colony
and yasenovats was croatia's penal
colony
that there weren't massive deaths there
was no epidemics or anything of the sort
and that if he had to do it he would do
it again
and at the end of the conversation he
made a comment i will never forget
he said he said to comrade so listen you
don't get it
the problem with your cenovats was they
didn't let us finish the job
how many would you say are still alive
i i there are at least hundreds at least
if you if you accept my definition of a
nazi war criminal which is anyone
who in the service of the third reich
participated
in the persecution and or murder of
innocent civilians
they're at least hundreds still alive so
so why is that that some countries
uh are so hesitant to to bring
bring these people to trial first of all
the embarrassment
in other words if their nationals are
involved in these terrible crimes
it's an embarrassment for the country
they're
terrible publicity big expenses
and they know the person will die and
and they'll spare them the embarrassment
the expense and the
ca you know and the whole mess around
the trial like that
what about the scandinavian countries
do you really want to know i'm not sure
now
well if i if i wouldn't want to know but
i know that's the problem
so first of all sweden and norway
were the only western democracies where
the statute of limitation on murder
also included genocide war crimes and
crimes against humanity
in other words there are other countries
like germany that have a
statute of limitation on for example
regular murder your pardon the use of
that term okay
but not for genocide not for war crimes
not for crimes against humanity
uh in sweden and in norway it's 25 years
and as a result when we gave
in a list of suspects to the swedish
government they
immediately informed us that they can't
do anything about it because of that
statute of limitations
they finally changed it but didn't make
the change retroactive
in other words norway in 2008 i think in
sweden in 2011
changed it to include to in other words
so that the statute of limitations would
not apply
to genocide war crimes and crimes
against humanity and no
in norway they added terror as well
so but some some people claim that
these people are 90 to 100 100 years old
why why why bother why why just don't
i mean why prosecute them when they are
so old well what do you answer them
first of all the passage of time
in no way diminishes the guilt of the
killers
they're just as guilty today as they
were then
old age should not afford protection to
people who committed such heinous
crimes we owe it to the victims to their
victims innocent people
who who were murdered simply because
they were categorized
as enemies of the reich this also sends
a powerful message
that if you commit crimes like this even
years later
there will be attempts to try and hold
you accountable
these trials also help in the fight
against holocaust denial
and what i call holocaust distortion
which is the rewriting of history now
in eastern europe to hide the role of
the local nazi collaborators
but even beyond that you know these are
the last people on earth who deserve any
sympathy
when you look at them you'll see people
who are elderly
and usually when a nazi is about to be
exposed or
put on trial they immediately go into
sick mode they try to look as sick as
possible
to convince you the innocent observer
that this is a total waste of time and
money i sometimes refer to that disease
as reason throttlitis
you know what i mean so but think about
it
when did they commit these crimes when
they committed these crimes
they were at the height of their
physical powers young men
full of energy and strength and some of
their victims were
older than they are today
and i'll just add one last point and
that is then all my experience
i've never had a case in which a case
that i was involved
to a large extent in which a single nazi
war criminal ever expressed any regret
or remorse so
no one has turned themselves in because
they couldn't
live with what they had done
there's never been a case like that
never listening to all this
one wonders who becomes a war criminal
uh is that something that we all have in
us
uh under the the wrong circumstances
or is it do you believe that some people
are just
born evil listen first of all
there are some people who are born evil
they're a distinct minority
the one of the most shocking things for
me was that i realized that almost all
the people i was dealing with
were normative people they had never
been involved in criminal activity
before the war
they were not involved in criminally
with one exception they were not
involved in criminal activity after the
war
and they led relatively normal lives
okay and this is the horror of the
holocaust the nazis
were able to create a set of
geopolitical circumstances
in which even normative people who
otherwise would never have been involved
in crimes like committed crimes like
this
it was more normal to kill a jew than to
save a jew
but not everyone could become a criminal
because
we have the example the wonderful
examples of the righteous among the
nations
people who risked their lives to save
jews and
you know in theory they could have been
criminals but they didn't become
criminals they became angels
saviors and if as i'm sitting here with
a 24 year old
a different generation what one
advice would you would you give to a 24
year old today
okay i would say to a 24 year old is one
of the things you should know
and this most people still don't know
about the holocaust
is that no person was ever executed for
refusing to kill
jews in other words people
did have a choice
and that's puts everything into a
different light
because if they had a choice and they
turned it down
then obviously they're guilty really
guilty
so this whole you know a lot of people
tried a lot of criminals tried the
superior orders defense someone with the
higher officer gave me an order i had to
vary out but we know that
in many many cases these men were given
the choice
and some some really turned it down some
decided they don't want to shoot
i just want to say something because um
maybe 10 years ago i was visiting
auschwitz and also birkinau and
to me was you know it's the most awful
sight
and and it really you know scarred me
for life but at the same time i feel
like it's so important that people like
you
and and all others educate my generation
about these things because
we learn from history and i think it's
really important so i just want to say
that i really admire your work and
i want to thank you for your service
thank you thank you very much dr zurov
thank you so much
you